les stars qui ne veulent pas d'enfants
encore une masero donc effectivement
j'ai jamais eu voulu d'enfant j'ai subi
des interruptions volontaires de
grossesse je ne veux pas imposer la
personne que je suis
ce que je vis à quelqu'un c'est une
responsabilité énorme et je ne n'ai
aucune honte Valérie Lemercier elle a
dit que c'est parce qu'elle pouvait pas
mais malgré tout elle dit j'ai pas pu
avoir d'enfant mais je ne porte pas
l'envie d'être mère Chimène Badi là on a
un extrait
donc moi l'idée de porte un enfant
d'avoir mon corps qui se transforme je
comprends c'est quelque chose qui pour
moi me paraît impossible je comprends
oui je dirais ce lien avec
avec le corps je dirais toutes ces
angoisses et toute cette peur qui font
que je pourrais empêcher mon enfant de
s'épanouir
et d'avoir j'aurais peur pour lui toutes
les secondes quoi ça je le sais donc du
coup forcément je ne m'épanouirai pas
non plus et la peur de perdre votre vie
en fait votre vie la peur
et dernière on en passe la dernière ça
c'est Béatrice Dalle et puis après
j'aimerais avoir un débat entre vous
parce que ça fait parler
c'est ça au fond la femme puissante ce
serait ça c'est d'être indépendante de
toutes les manières je vais être
dépendant de rien ni de personnes c'est
pour ça aussi je crois que j'ai pas fait
d'enfants parce que je pourrais pas
assumer cette dépendance c'est
impossible alors j'adore les enfants du
A1 mais qui a été vite réglée
l'horloge biologique à jamais de plus en
plus de femmes qui prennent la décision
n'est pas là forcément pour mettre bas
c'est ce que Elisabeth Badinter je
t'aime Isabelle
pas choqué et vous êtes totalement libre
de le de le penser
il y a un choqué de Florian tu regardes
tes enfants un homme comme ça
oui je suis un petit peu choqué parce
que il y a aussi beaucoup beaucoup de
personnalités qui ont du mal à avoir des
enfants parce que c'est vrai que c'est
un sujet c'est de plus en plus compliqué
d'avoir des enfants l'autre jour et qui
regardent la télévision qui lisent les
articles ont pas forcément vraiment
besoin d'avoir des de lire de voir des
gens qui se répandent sur ce sujet avec
cette espèce de nonchalance qui peut
être un peu gênante mais alors des
charges rajouterais un truc c'est que
c'est vrai que nous les journalistes le
premier truc qu'on fait souvent quand on
est interview une femme de plus de 30
ans c'est de demander est-ce que vous
voulez des enfants est-ce que vous
regrettez de pas avoir d'enfants etc
donc ils sont un peu obligés de répondre
donc c'est pas forcément comment
les cheveux alors tu lèves la main comme
Chantal kebilingue qui nous répondent en
anglais parce que ses enfants tournent
dans une école bilingue
j'aimerais bien en avoir j'aimerais bien
avoir quatre ou cinq après
on est cinq chez moi donc j'aimerais
bien avoir dépêche-toi il va falloir
attaquer le souci c'est que juste la
responsabilité je pense qu'à partir du
moment où tu te sens pas capable
d'élever un enfant encore heureux que je
suis dans fasses pas parce que moi
d'enfants malheureusement être là alors
qu'ils ont rien demandé leurs parents
étaient pas capables de s'en occuper
est-ce que je peux poser une question je
pose se met à pavé dans la mare et vous
jouez dans la mare vous plongez je mets
le pavé il y a aussi beaucoup d'actrices
qui disent ce monde est trop dur je ne
veux pas leur laisser ce monde et qui en
offre quand on dîne avec et ça m'est
déjà arrivé elle te disent je pas de
vergetures je veux pas les seins qui
tombent je veux pas abîmer mon corps je
suis actrice je suis actrice Jean-Michel
maire qui connaît les femmes bah bien
sûr excuse-moi moi le fait qu'elle
veulent pas d'enfant j'ai absolument
rien contre chacun fait ce qu'il veut
moi c'est les raisons évoqué qui me
semble absolument incroyable le fait
Chimène Badi je veux pas que mon corps
c'est bien c'est bien un mec qui parle
non c'est honnête mais c'est ce qu'on
est bien un homme mais si excuse-moi il
y a rien de plus beau pour une femme que
ou pour un père bah j'ai des enfants
donc c'est pour ça
[Rires]
et vous savez quoi quand bien même une
femme ne voudrait pas d'enfant parce
qu'elle a peur d'abîmer son corps est-ce
que là encore on peut l'en vouloir
premièrement longtemps on l'a
culpabilisé les femmes qui n'avaient pas
non absolument c'était limite une onde
sociale absolument et ben pour une fois
qu'on les culbute c'est génial il y a
aucune raison de vouloir absolument des
enfants tu peux respecter le choix de
femme qui disent voilà c'est une charge
non parce que c'est facile les paroles
de mec comme tu fais là tu sais très
bien et de notre génération la charge
mentale des enfants sont souvent les
femmes qui l'ont c'est pas les mecs qui
vont c'est pas les mecs à l'école
ça c'est nouveau dans la nouvelle
génération c'est très bien mais la
plupart du temps c'est les femmes qui
s'occupaient de ça donc c'est très
facile de dire oui mais Laurent je pose
une question en revanche là où je
Jean-Michel sur un truc la raison qui
est le monde va si mal je me sentirai
responsable de mettre un enfant dans un
monde avec l'écologie qui parle ça ça
concerne pas
que les Philippines ça ne concerne pas
que les femmes parce que maintenant on
pourrait se poser la même question mais
c'est hyper intelligent ce qu'il
vient de dire pareil un mec pourrait
dire je veux pas faire l'enfant à une
femme parce que là pardon c'est très
intéressant
[Rires]
la semaine dernière sur Twitter Isa Isa
Isa Isa c'est là qu'on voit que je suis
pas crédible on entend des moins ta
grande gueule quand tu étais Luna qui
présentait oui le temps joue pas pour
elle non
pas tomber enceinte non mais moi je
voulais pas d'enfant donc je suis alors
une seconde j'aimerais la dire attendez
pardon une seconde s'il vous plaît pas
exactement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais il y a une phrase pardon la phrase
la plus intelligente que je trouvais sur
ce plateau c'est Philippe
à ton enfant pareil le père est
responsable les mecs
pour répondre à cette raison là que tu
évoqué fait de dire c'est parce que ce
monde est pourri j'ai pas envie de
laisser les enfants moi l'homme et la
femme se pose la même question d'accord
certains et donc je suis pas une femme
je sais pas quel est le si on a vraiment
un désir ou si c'est un devoir un moment
donné moi je pense qu'on le fait un
moment donné dans sa vie plus tard avec
le temps je pense qu'il y a des regrets
après on se laisse croire que non je
n'en voulais pas parce qu'elles sont pas
ça à côté mais je pense que le fait
d'avoir un enfant deux hommes qui
parlent moi je pense que la maternité tu
l'as encore ou pas pour avoir un enfant
que ce soit l'homme alors l'enfant c'est
quand même le sujet qui fait Benoît on a
envie de vieillir accompagné on a envie
d'avoir on a envie de d'échanger
d'apprendre
une seconde parce que
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai gagné un caméscope 100 €. j'ai fait
un peu le flash moi
je l'ai accepté parce que j'aurais pu ne
pas le garder puisqu'on arrive
alors
[Rires]
je fais ce que je veux de mon corps ce
que je n'ai jamais pensé donc j'aurais
pu très bien ne pas le garder tout ce
que toutes mes copines me conseillaient
de faire les Ultra féministes que je
n'étais pas et moi je me suis dit bon
ben je l'ai je le garde
et j'ai adoré l'état de grossesse mais
les raisons qui fait que je n'avais pas
de devises d'enfants n'ont pas changé je
n'avais pas de désir d'enfant et en plus
effectivement j'étais traumatisé par la
démographie mondiale et je ne voulais
pas participer alors juste ce qui est
mon droit le plus stricte mais on t'a
pas eu le contraire ne parlez pas tout
ça ne parlez pas tous en même temps et
ben juste faire une dédicace à un garçon
que j'adore qui s'appelle Guillaume
c'est ton fils tu n'as pas été désiré
mais tu étais bon tu as gardé peut-être
accepter dans une boîte à chaussures
et voilà c'est comme ça le désirez pour
de mais effectivement je me suis baissé
direct
et on creuse un peu
et je suis ravie que ce soit devenu un
homme bien et là pour le coup on y est
pour quelque chose alors attention je
parle à Sophie qui a trois enfants mais
qui ne parle que l'Américain la langue
de demain salut
d'abord moi j'ai toujours voulu avoir
des enfants moi mes parents ont pas pu
avoir d'enfant donc ma mère a dû adopter
donc j'ai été adopter donc voilà c'est
une histoire
mais vous me faites des hits dans cette
phrase dans cette émission
elle a fait beaucoup de fausses couches
et il y avait une pression sociale c'est
vrai à l'époque bon voilà c'était il y a
45 ans mais aujourd'hui aussi je trouve
qu'il y a plein de jeunes filles à qui
on dit il y a cette espèce de
d'injonction à être mère absolument et
on peut ne pas avoir le désir moi
j'avais un désir absolu quoi de
peut-être de par mon histoire j'en sais
rien mais je voulais je savais que je
voulais être maman et je suis une super
maman donc genre c'est mon job préféré
quoi j'adore ça
[Rires]
les accepter allez c'est il y a aussi
une question de je suis d'accord de
regard sur la vie aussi moi je trouve la
vie tellement belle je trouve qu'on a
tellement de chance j'avais envie de
transmettre ça quoi des je suis pas du
tout dans un truc où je me dis ah c'est
naze très bien c'est très bien super etc
voilà elle a tout expliqué dans dans ses
bouquins
j'ai
décrochés moi
Isabelle arrête-toi là
coupez-la coupez-la
comme mes neveux je me suis occupé
toujours contre foutu
ah ben non c'est un texte de ton fils et
lui qui s'est barré paraguette ah bah
tiens